And use case #2
is to use the BigQuery
for signature based search
based on the result you got
from the data model.
You're trying to use
the machine learning engine.
We use the ML engine for
extracting the feature vectors.
So I'd like to show
another demonstration
of QueryIt Smart.
So if you go to QueryIt Smart,
you have another demonstration
called "image search."
And you can choose one
of the key images.
Let me try with the elephant.
So we're gonna be using
this elephant image
as a key image
and compare 1 million images
with this image
to find the similar images
on BigQuery.
And we got it.
AndBigQuery has processed
8.8 gigabit
of data over 1 million images
in 10 seconds,
and all you see
is the similar images.
And you may notice that
you also have the images
that is not elephant.
Like this.
This is not an elephant,
but still it looks same.
It looks similar
to the neural networks.
And this apparently
is not an animal.
It's a statue, but still
the neural network thinks
it must be similar thing.
This is not an elephant,
but it has the same kind of
the texture of patterns,
so the neural network thinks
they are similar.
So this is not a keyword search
or pattern matching,
but they are comparing the--
all the feature look just--
or signatures of the images.
So you can get the much smarter
search on the BigQuery.
So how do you do this?
At first, we have imported
all the 1 million images
from Wikimedia
on the Google Cloud Storage.
And then we have used
machine learning engine--
ML Engine to learn the
convolution on neural networks
on the ML Engine.
This is a typical neural network
design
used while analyzing the images.
But usually people are using CNN
to get the labels
for the images,
such as "is it a cat?
"Is it a human face?
Is it flower?"
But instead of getting labels,
we are using CNN to extract
the feature vectors
that could be in signatures
of our images.
And by using the BigQuery
and UDF,
you can do the similarity search
against images.
And all--we have used VGG16,
which is a popular CNN design,
and we are extracting
the feature vectors
from the final fully
connectional layers.